. I often talk about the importance of
learning and teaching, media literacy,
media criticism, epistemology, the thinking
arts, so to speak. And I also talk about
the absolute and total lack of those in our
country among large swaths of the population
today. I'm going to go through one 90 second
news, Max clip Newsmax is this kind of radical
alternative to Fox News. And we're going to try to
look at how many lies, how many distortions, how
many baseless assumptions can we find. So this is
it's actually kind of hard for me to tell you what
the segment is about. I guess the segment is sort
of about so-called cancer culture type content.
And the segment claims that the left is nothing
short of Marxist authoritarian dictators of some
kind. So let's take it piece by piece and you're
going to see how quickly their builds a pyramid of
so much that is wrong in this segment. And because
there's so much unless you are really armed with
critical thinking faculties, just by the sheer
number of deceptions and misstatements here,
you'll probably fall for some of it.
So let's begin with the first part of this
here today, our culture. This is happening.
Marxists have used the hollow shell of
the Democratic Party to ascend to power.
OK, so there are no Marxists in the American
Democratic Party. The closest you might get in the
Senate is Bernie, who calls himself a Democratic
socialist. Maybe he was a Democratic socialist
in his younger years. He advocates for standard
northern European social democracy, not Marxism.
There's no Marxism in the U.S. Senate. In the
House, he calls herself a Democratic socialist.
There are some other members of Congress who use
that term. They aren't Marxists. And certainly
no Marxists have any power in the United States.
They've not taken over the Democratic Party
in any way, shape or form. So already the
segment is lined up with a bogus framing, a
bogus base to this pyramid of disinformation.
Let's keep going and do what they have always
wanted to do in this country and what they
do in every country destroy the history and
culture of the nation that they have taken over.
No history has been destroyed and certainly
no culture has been destroyed. Culture
evolve. The culture is something that evolves
over time, politically, economically, intellectual
culture. All participants in a culture shape it
either explicitly or implicitly. It's essentially
a meaningless fear mongering statement meant
to resonate in what we know are the fear
oriented brains of conservatives. Next clip.
This year alone, we have seen Kermit the Frog,
Mr. Potato Head, Dr. Seuss, Star Wars characters,
pancake sirup butter and beloved sports teams
logos. Band erased from history.
Now, this one is really a doozy.
None of that is true in any real sense. And this
is a Gish Gallop. The whole segment is a Gish
Gallop. But this set of examples is a it's a it's
a Gish gallop within a gallop. Kermit the Frog.
Some episodes have depictions of Native Americans
and Middle Eastern people that are not great.
And some Muppet Show episodes now have a warning
at the beginning. They're not banned. They have a
warning at the beginning. Mr. Potato Head had its
franchise name changed to Potato Head. Both Mr.
and Mrs. Potato Head still exist. Dr. Seuss,
we've been talking about the publishing company,
decided not to keep publishing six books
due to stereotypes of Asian people. In them,
nothing is banned. Star Wars characters, I
guess he's referring to the Mandalorian star,
Gina Carano, who was fired because she implied
that being a Republican today is like being Jewish
during the Holocaust and a private company decided
what's good for them. It's not very Marxist for
private, for profit companies to be allowed to do
whatever they want, but that is market capitalism
that we have in the United States. Pancake sirup
is Aunt Jemima sirup being renamed because the
imagery of Aunt Jemima is quite crass today, given
how it stereotypes black Americans. The sirup is
still around. It's just called Pearl Milling. It's
not on Jemima anymore. Butter. I don't even know
what he's talking about. I wasn't even able to
find anything on that one. Sports team logos. Yes.
You know, Washington Redskins with a caricature
of a red skinned Native American stereotype.
It just doesn't it's unflattering and it's
inappropriate at this point. And the team
decided this is bad for us. So we're going to
change the team name. And now the host says these
aren't merely decisions by private companies.
These are not simply marketing choices of
private companies. We want to emphasize
this. Joe Biden's White House endorses
these modern day book burnings. The White
House, the most powerful seat in our land.
Biden broke with longstanding tradition
and refused to acknowledge Dr. Seuss on his
birthday this very week, he refused to recommend
that children read beloved Dr. Seuss books.
So he implies Joe Biden has weighed
in on that list of things he gave
and Joe Biden hasn't. Joe Biden went along with
what read across America Day did, which is they
don't include Dr. Seuss. Biden hasn't endorsed any
of the other stuff the guy listed. He hasn't even
mentioned most of it at all. One more clip here.
Amazon then stopped selling certain Dr. Seuss
titles and publishers halted printing them
entirely. Here are real screenshots from an
eBay user getting blocked for trying to sell
a Dr. Seuss book because it is, and I quote,
offensive material. We verified these images
are real. What's also real, real shocking is
that Hitler's Mein Kampf is still available
for sale on eBay. This is a book literally
about racism. This is a book literally calling
for book burnings. You can't make this up.
So then he raises Amazon. Should Amazon not
be allowed to do what they want? I mean,
is the argument from free market capitalist
Newsmax that Amazon shouldn't be allowed,
Amazon should be forced to do something, eBay
should be forced to sell books. Who would force
them? The government? That's not small government,
conservative conservatism. And arguably his only
maybe good point comes at the end, which is why
is Hitler's book still available? Shouldn't there
be some consistency here? I personally
think there should be. That being said,
it's ultimately the decision of eBay. So there is
essentially nothing in this rant that is accurate
or relevant to the real world. But people watch
this stuff and they fall hook, line and sinker
for it. Let me know what you think.
We'll have more coverage of these
types of segments on The David Pakman Show
Instagram page bindis there at David Pakman show